I don't have precise um bright-line
thing there and obviously obviously if
you say that we should just get rid of
everything all together and the people
have you know everybody have their own
nuclear bombs and stuff like that and
let people solve things by themselves
that's obviously not the right the right
answer either I think that something
like a state about you know a government
that has that spends maybe 10 to 15
percent of GDP is about the right number
so you know and I think we can have
political debates as to where that money
best be spent countries like Hong Kong
you know number the emerging markets
have done really well seem to have been
stable they've had institutions that you
know have protected people from crime
and it was protected property rights and
have you know they've not been
completely chaotic unstable places and
they've achieved tremendous our rates of
growth and I think I think one of the
one of the perspective that's always
very important is a long time horizon
because I think you know one of these
debates is always that on a short time
horizon of course you get all sorts of
different priorities but if the question
is how do we create the best world in
the next 50 years the next hundred years
or or beyond I think you get two very
different answers from if you ask what
do we do that's the best for the next
two years the next four you know the
next political election cycle
obviously is a very significant tension
and the security problem you know is a
difficult one for libertarians to tackle
I mean it's probably this you know
children are problem for libertarians
crazy people are problem for
libertarians and you're criminals are a
problem and I consider you know
terrorists are sort of a probably a
subset of crazy people and and criminals
at the same time but but that but that
being said I do think that there there
there should be ways to to to to address
this that there's obviously um there's
there's one set of arguments on I
wouldn't say the panacea at all but
there is definitely a one-one line of
analysis that that it is that terrorism
tends to arise most in parts of the
world that are very disconnected from
the rest and so that if we have a more
connected world in which people feel
they have a stake in what happens in
different places in different countries
that will create some you know some some
incentives to to basically to do that
will mitigate against against sort of
the kind of runaway hostility that that
is very very dangerous I don't think
that's a panacea I think that certainly
is a partial things I think
globalization is not the whole answer
but it is probably a partial answer to
some of the things that are that are
driving I'm driving things towards
towards terrorism and then of course you
know I do think there are they're pieces
of it that could be dealt with in a
variety of ways so you know I think if
you could reduce the energy dependency
in the US this would be a very important
step in in effect defunding a lot of the
terrorist organizations if you could
there probably are a whole set of
security measures one could take that
don't necessarily are not necessarily
incompatible with global